welcome to this video round seven
coverage of the gushy move memorial and
some yellow if you look at the pairings
for this round you sort of immediately
think that the game of the day must be
Nakamura versus Carlson and indeed it is
not because while on paper it sounds
like the most interesting pairing but in
fact it also was the by far most
interesting game of this round I'm brief
word about the two other games we had to
a job of playing mama D are offered job
of being the co-leader of this
tournament with this win against
karsland a couple of drawers he played
the draw against no major of a pretty
unpretty an exciting game out of an
English opening English Ready Set type
of opening worldwide sometimes as a tiny
edge but it quickly evaporated into
nothing mkay yakeen kar awana was a
longer game so almost 50 moves it was
quite funny to to see that for the first
29 moved both players only spent like
five minutes in a theoretical greenford
it's sometimes really a bit sick if you
look at those kind of games where you
see that more than half of the game 30
moves 29 moose was prepared beforehand
um looked like a hawk and maybe has some
practical chances but okay kawana
defended this precisely to a draw so it
it really comes to through the game you
all expect to be the game of the day m
and I camera playing cousin of course
there is a big history already between
the two players well Nakamura has lost
nine classical time control games and
didn't one even a single game I mean
it's 90 with a couple of drawers and it
the trend is not exactly great for like
a mora he had a totally winning position
in
Zurich and lost it and he also lost in
the second round of this tournament
where it was a pretty pretty red of a
clear fair I mean come where I wasn't
winning at any point or even better in
this in this game in the second round so
let's see what happened to unicameral
playing white is going for the new zone
would have three yeah one of the really
topical lines nowadays which was
expected in a way um about two and a
half years ago when i did this small
video series on my channel on the d4 up
to i also recommended f3 well it's not
like the top layers watch my channel i'd
say well he f three he's a good move but
back then it it already was clear that
are three is one of the the sharpest
rise it and it sets like serious not
problems is but it's a challenge in a
way because why this really intending to
to get this this big center and like
cannot play any sort of second-rate
setups yeah he must really know what
he's doing Carlton has faced this really
a number of times against Nakamura
against Arnold against kayak in early at
the tournament against Kaia Kanepi
castles after HIV we had no p12 h5 hit
this position and hasn't got a really
good position out of the opening here
he's going for c5 interesting choice
explain later why and d5 castles efore
and 26 yeah it's very interesting for me
to to watch this because as you probably
know I'm working on a book on the names
of Indian and bogo Indian playing a
blood presenting a black repertoire and
this is my repertoire choice against f3
in this book I'm analyzing the DC
line he has cars and played and also be
five which is even sharper so I was very
curious to see how this game of course
went because um I can I can compare it
with my my almost finished yeah what's
the word my almost finished document sir
for the book and analysis um after this
White's main moves on lie to e2 and
Bishop to d3 Bishop d3 black can play b5
again playing in gambit style very
interesting wider shouldn't even take
the pawn and after night e to their also
black and play a quick b5 this is very
interesting and sharp line under now can
we replace bishop d to which can
transpose 292 really it leads to the
same pain same structure at least um
here of course be five is simply
prevented because white can take with
the night this doesn't work any sense
but what i can do is can develop the
night first 97 and yeah the the problem
of all these f three setups in the NIMS
aware in the Samish and other lines and
the deform my complex is always that
this night does not have a normal
development square development
developing square and it needs to travel
mostly to g3 so 92 was played 95
threatening meet by the way it's quite
funny why shouldn't play a three or
something i need to put it on the border
or a checkmate think this is quite funny
so of course the night went to g3 and
now after the capture and wide
recaptures we get a structure that in my
book I called an Enzo benoni not sure if
this is an
official official term but it is a
benoni structure d6c five against this
pawn chain a typical structure from the
modern benoni where the bishop is on
before instead of g7 with the fianchetto
this of course is some very a
substantial difference and it's not so
clear if it works in any any sites favor
really it has some advantages it has
some disadvantages of course the bishop
on g7 is not not badly placed the long
diagonal is quite quite nice to sit on
but g6 on the other hand can also be
weakness on the King side if you imagine
the pawn being on g6 okay there is a
bishop on g7 but still there is some
weakness weiter sometimes can exchange
the dark squared bishop player for get
an attack this is not so easy to do here
sometimes black even has a square on g6
for the night which sometimes is tricky
in the modern bin only because the G 640
square is always occupied by the pond so
the night only 5 does not have a good to
retreat square in case of a being
attacked you had another issue with the
bishop here on before it's quite often
it can be useful on b6 we'll see that
later in the game yeah Bishop d7 a3 not
sure if this is strictly necessary but
it's not a bad move very often on black
will play Bishop f5 anyway so ok Bishop
f5 there should be two and now council
plays b5 immediately does not really
need to move a 6 here the point is that
white cannot really take on b5 if we
look at this briefly night XP 5 is the
only capture to to even consider after
that you see that c4 is some very
annoying for white there is play on the
be foul and there is night to d3 so very
a very good play for black white
shouldn't do that
you just canceled which is which is just
better and now see form yeah this is the
structure and that usually I'm develops
from this line with black having the
school's policy on d5 and sir 1c for
this sometimes ensures a good square on
d3 at the moment of course the bishop on
e2 is protecting that but it sometimes
gives a good square here also be 3 can
be a useful post for the night if you
imagine the night being on c5 for
example enter of course the bishop can
be placed on b6 which normally leads to
a trade of those pieces as white cannot
really tolerate a bishop on b6 this is
exactly what happens in the game yeah
why does not want to take on b6 and
allow recapture with check so all those
moves look fairly normal to me night do
you one now when I camera that's
interesting move really it intends a
regrouping to e3 maybe even recapturing
with the night and this would send the
second night towards the f5 square this
is of course also a difference compared
to the modern benoni where the g6 pawn
is always controlling at five this is
not happening here and black can rarely
play pawn to g6 after the dark sky
bishops I exchange so this is a
difference that black needs to be aware
and is also here on d1 it looks at those
squares and might even support further
a4 push I think around here the position
is probably somewhere between to an
equal and slightly slightly better for
white maybe but it's a it's a very
interesting and complicated position so
I think black should be afraid to to
play this the structure
um here there's an interesting
interesting moment and something where
I'm not sure if this is the right setup
it's interesting cars are now plays
Bishop back to c 8 which it first looks
a bit weird why would he sort of
undeveloped the piece um it has an
interesting idea though he wants to free
d 7 for the night so that this maneuver
is possible that's very interesting and
maybe a worth spending time form I'm not
sure in the game it does not really lead
to such a great position but I don't
really want to call it a mistake I'm
really not sure and the let's say normal
move fear is rupee 8 or let's say it
looks normal to me like putting the rook
here now maybe intensifying some
pressure on the four so that f-4s is
tougher to play if we consider just to
put some moves on the board king edge
one it's hard to to to do without the
move in the long run anyway king edge
one and let's say you go a five trying
to use your your majority here three
against two and yeah just let's say
something like that this feels like an
unclear position to me i don't i don't
really know how to how to assess it i
don't think black should be an in
terrible shape here white cannot so
easily push f4 and because II for as
always somewhat of a weakness yeah hard
to how to judge i mean i wouldn't mind
to play this with both sides it's it's
interesting to play okay well causal
played differently played Bishop to c8
king h1 and now Knight to d7 this was
the idea putting the night on c5 ok so
now f4 was played and night went back to
g6 yeah as mentioned this is very often
the retreats
well that now is is available because
there is no pawn on d6 um yeah here la
camara took on p6 here there was an
interesting alternative and this is a
form the this is recommended by by the
computer and in my case this is Houdini
what I use so a form not not a
revolutionary concept try to try to use
the a file it can lead to very very
interesting complications this for
example can be a quite interesting where
black is not that black you're
threatening 92 b3 and here white as has
two alternatives you can play Bishop to
d1 just defending this in a way
interesting with or white can can even
simply take which is interesting
something like that it's quite an
interesting sacrifice as c4 will fall
and then white as some yeah one to two
pawns and a very interesting space
advantage black is not very well
coordinated here I'm an interesting line
however there is also Bishop d1 as
mentioned which is interesting just to
covering v3 could also be quite good for
wide black in after a four also play a
six this is possible after that white
has sort of inserted this opening up the
a file which at the moment seems more to
White's advantage as he's got the look
on a one already there are also direct
attempts interestingly enough the
computer wants to play Bishop g4 which
looks as strange to me but in fact is
quite interesting yeah the idea
sometimes can be really just to take the
night
and then push the f porn with temple f5
f6 quite quite interesting idea um for
example if if black now it takes white
recaptures and 95 now this looks fairly
logical the new ID can take and put this
on f5 and this should be quite quite
good for what I think not like decisive
but yeah it looks it looks interesting
f4 was an interesting alternative I mean
Menachem Wallace move wasn't bad i'm
just pointing out some things that
needed to be a considered okay rook b6
is their only move really if like em
recaptures with with the Queen for
example there is there is a five and
after this there is f6 and why this
almost winning black gum cannot stand
this yeah this leads to a direct
checkmate now this is in fact very
important as the rook is not terribly
well placed on basics okay night m23
again a4 was an alternative 93-95 this
of course was the whole idea behind
Bishop c8 and then everything putting
the night on c5 okay Bishop d1 played
yeah to cover b3 and now the next move
played by Carlton is maybe maybe not
really good I mean it's very tough to
analyze this game because there are so
many possibilities are coming up and
it's difficult to determine the real
decisive that the turning points where
really am the game was er not decided
but when the important spots lie
yeah well this was played and it seems
that after after this white will get an
advantage maybe black needs to do
something something more passive I mean
if I read this correctly Carlton and the
press conference pointed out that he had
considered something like f6 and sort of
yeah just controlling a 5 making making
sort of a purely defensive move he had
considered but it does it looked like it
looked too passive to him um we were
then I can very much understand it looks
like a terribly passive move but maybe
just objectively speaking from an
analytical point of view this would have
been better he played 93 the more active
move em but it said it does not seem to
to to work out so so nicely and we see
em what happens nakamura place f5 good
move there also was this one quite
interesting actually covering f4 from
age 5 and you still have this IDM but
okay don't want to make a three hour
long video this was interesting it
wasn't necessarily better but also worth
considering f5 was good it leads to it
leads to a right edge with without any
any doubt night g2f for this is this is
forced actually yeah this looks far more
natural but unfortunately there is f6
and yeah if black plays g6 now otherwise
white will take care it's better to let
him take but just to show g6 there is 94
and black can resigned with the clear
conscience or whatever Queen age 6 is
winning so blank must go here and this
is the problem of the set up those two
nights I mean they're sort of their
invasion forces but they also tied
together you cannot move any of the
nights
so then the other one yeah well this
night does not have a square and a for
pretty and no this is crazy how can I do
that it was an accident I didn't okay
can let the pieces blink yeah well this
night it does not have a retreat square
and the whole thing I gets a guest
tactical now some concrete lines need to
be checked I think the camera is doing a
good job he plays a for this this idea
we have seen before opening up the a
file at the right moment and yeah a b5
would destroy black some structure so a
six must must be played until Nakamura
played 94 which is good it leads to a
white edge no doubt and there also was
the move B 3 which was interesting I
think focusing on the queenside after
that that's also difficult for black to
to find the really good news because but
white is just threatening to take on c4
twice and what exactly are you going to
do if black takes which maybe he needs
to do i'm not sure but it seems like
that then this night on d3 has lost its
its anchor and this easily imaginable
that those kind of nights i mean that
there should be some sort of material
loss coming up b3 was very interesting
but Nakamura's move was also strong it's
not like it it's a mistake Knight to g4
with a simple idea could take it and
after that black only has one reply it's
totally forced now I must play h5 yeah
they're only move otherwise why it just
takes and he just dropped back to f2 a
good move a good move there also was
rook takes a form which could could be
considered and it also seems to be quite
good for white I mean his move was
perfectly ok but this also was quite
strong I think
black probably needs to take on g4 as
night XF form is uncertain I this funny
huh desperado move which destroys black
structure black needs to take Queen
takes and now probably Queen g5 you
cannot really allow why to take so Queen
g5 and now Queen back to have to end
yeah here White has sacrificed an
exchange but the concrete lines are just
very good for white if you look at this
ya need students and now white can take
here and you notice that the Queen it
does not have many squares I can easily
get trapped the Queen let's say after
this quindi for there is this this very
strong threat something like that can
easily trap the Queen yeah white has
some very good chance here for the for
the exchange probably this is why after
group takes black should take on on g4
and well this is some after Luke g-form
just a pawn for the moment it's not
totally clear though after 95 because
white has also exchanged some some some
active active piece so it's not totally
clear let's say rook f4 there's also a
five by the way quite interesting look a
for Queen g5 is not totally clear black
has activated somewhat you had this a 5
News also interesting so rook takes f
form here in this position was a was an
interesting alternative accountant and
Nakamura's move is good though no no
point of criticism them um yeah here
comes a plate Queen to f6 which is again
probably forced it's not I didn't I
don't really see any alternate if you
need to activate the Queen here
to get this play going something like
let's say that this capture is something
like that is almost hopeless there is f6
coming night to h5 you you just have a
weak King side with little defensive
forces so he needed to do that and here
here we come to a very very important
spot it sir there are many in this game
but here is this very important it seems
that in this position like Amber I
really could have could have gotten a
huge advantage as I already sort of
spoiled it he didn't didn't play the
move he took on d3 which still keeps an
advantage yeah it's not terribly bad but
it seems that night takes h5 was strong
here and it has the very nice yeah
what's very nice it's so post only
forced black can a must recapture here
what what else is there and now night XD
3 seat XD and a 5 yeah and this seems to
be very good for what if we consider now
the rook moves the hour b7 obviate I'm
not quite sure actually may be here
Bishop takes h5 yeah maybe rupee a dress
better I'm not quite sure but okay if we
just consider the the whole the whole
thing here white now access to two ways
to go it can play be four and then try
to capture these three just for free or
you can even take d3 now because of the
Queen takes there is also this f6 moves
here which is probably quite promising
for what um this looks very very good
for what maybe before it's even better
as you cannot really keep the poor near
there is also sometimes this
to get it note that in this structure
the bishop on the seventh is totally
dead I mean this is just terrible piece
and this is the real problem here it's
not just the part I mean why this
probably one to two pawns up in the near
future but this Bishop on d 7 is just
terrible and there is not much what
black can do against it really it's
totally force night age 5 what should
like do you cannot play a let's say a
queen here less noisy for its it's
really did very really a fast line and
very good for white and this is no
cameras move and it also keeps an
advantage but it is not so clear in in
comparison it took recaptured of course
and now queen III here night x h 5 lakh
can play Queen B 2 which is also not bad
for what you can you can play that
Bishop c2 and then play for an attack on
the king it's not very convincing but
you can do it this is better Queen III
neck and watch movies better now i will
look b7 now this was just attacked the
rook and the computer suggests night c5
but this is a terrible self pin I mean
suggests means it's not like super great
but it looks very unnatural for human so
rugby 7s is okay and now we took on h5
in fact here I think white head has also
an improvement night h5 is also good for
lighting that's a takes be first it's
probably somewhat better in comparison
and the idea is after eight xb9 age five
green age six this is very similar to
the game we will see that but now white
can play Queen deform keeping the
Queen's on and well obviously the Queen
on d4 is quite nice putting the Queen in
this central square and this also looks
very promising for
if you consider what exactly is Plex
idea now the bishop on c8 is here very
sorry piece probably something like rook
here and rugby is seven but it should be
good for why 200 okay six maybe him
attacking here it looks quite good for
while I think it's it's somewhat better
than the game in the game it was it was
very you can compare this so Queen age
six and now a difference is now queen
deform if you look at this this is not
so clear because black can no tape here
getting some play on B to the a file
it's not open I can consider this move
to after this recapture with the bishop
after which the bishop is at least
somewhat activated I guess this didn't
appear to Nakamura so he exchanged on
age six and also take note right is a
pawn up the whole time it's not like a
black is having extra material or
anything why does entering a hero yeah I
cannot yeah it's almost an endgame
within with an extra pawn took their
took them now a plate Bishop c2 um very
interesting spot in fact um b2 is
hanging and should white defend it very
interesting question um the computer
actually suggests rupee one within with
the width height advantage which I find
quite remarkable because it looks a bit
strange but very passive yeah black will
play rook a seven I mean white advantage
very small advantage because black gets
this activity here and this should be
okay really for black now can we
replayed Bishop c2 which is much more
active and I think also the more more
human move freely and here's interesting
I think
really could have taken on be too I
didn't have the opportunity to to watch
the game live today or the press
conference as i was playing myself um in
a league game so i don't know what both
players said about night takes between
Calvin could have taken on b2 here and
it would be interesting to learn because
um well if you look at it with with
engine assistance it just gives it 000
of course it's not an easy thing to to
assess this because white definitely has
has an attack going this is clear so I
understand that maybe it just seemed
seemed risky to Carla um yeah white can
give this check which is a very obvious
way to play after this check you can
easily have a perpetual on the other
hand white can also play something like
that try to to get this this attack
going and this can lead to two very
sharp lines for example before check
check and now Luke a six which is
obviously very sharp intending ya to
take on d6 and then get this meat in of
course black has some things himself can
cover here Luke c6 b3 for example yeah
now white can can take here this is a
very interesting position which is very
difficult to assess white as the moment
two pawns for the piece but an
overwhelming position to the knight on
f6 or piece is active yeah the computer
is just giving it a 000 probably leading
to some sort of Perpetual but this is
possible I don't know it's it's very
tricky and maybe a night that be too is
definitely it seems better than the game
but tough to assess I cards and drop
back to e5
and after that it seems that why should
be better again play droog a 6 root d8
and starting from here it it it goes
wrong for white yeah you sort of i mean
really if you if you have seen the
history of games between the two players
lok hammer already had some good
positions i mean okay the one that he
had in Zurich Zurich this plus 10 or
whatever position well this is not
comparable but this is still a very nice
position for white after black had
retreated to e5 white has a pawn at the
moment but of course he needs to be a
very alert about those pawns here b5 NC
4 flex ideas to push the pawns and
promote one of them and while white has
upon which is basically the Jeep on that
just got lost for black yeah but what
white also ass has got the active rook
active night so he should try to convert
the poem in the long run and he must
avoid that those pawns and get too
dangerous and it seems that with time
running running low Nakamura does not
find the right piece coordination it it
really goes yeah in the wrong way now
for him he plays tonight to g3 which is
maybe this the first step in the in the
wrong direction some some moves like
that say rook see one norm maybe a
prophylactically moving the rook away
maybe Luke a eight something like that
it's maybe better it's not easy to
analyze really i only had limited time
as mentioned i was away the whole day to
play myself oh it's difficult to to tell
what's the best movies really but this
seems to be too slow and we see that
after rugby 8 yeah this is preventing
Ruge a 8 and it prepares no along in the
long run
b7 look a seven was played now before
and now nighty too yeah this was
obviously the idea nakamura wanted to
get the night over to d4 which looks
logical really but the the big problem
was after Bishop d7 I think here he
really should play the light to deform
which she didn't strangely enough I
think 94 was really the logical
follow-up after after all that I mean
black bye-bye now has some some play I
mean be three for example and now whom
let's say not sure ooh kade rook c8
those moves are I interesting even this
is interesting yeah always note that if
you if you assess a position with the
uneven material here why does it porn up
try to assess the position one idea is
if you are not sure am I really a pawn
up am I plus one if you if you live in
computer terms yeah if you want an
additional tool or help to assess just
put a pawn on g7 in your mind and try to
assess this position if you feel that
with a porn on g7 you would be worse as
right really worse then you don't really
happen have a clear extra porn and in
fact if black would have a porn on g7
gyro porn on g5 let's say it was would
be very very clear that black is better
because the ponyo is dangerous and it's
a great night only 5 and so on so white
must be very precisely it's not like he
has an extra point for nothing um yeah
this this was very slow this maneuver
here this night maneuvers starting here
was g3 e 2 and so on it really gave
cards and lots of activity on the on the
queenside yeah but here rook a one was
played
after that it gets tricky for white
really really tricky mission b5 well as
much 94 should have been played the
computer also should suggest a very
funny move in my book because it looks
very unhuman look b1 not really sure
what this is doing I mean it's sort of
works against the pawns but it's not a
move that would come easy to you really
and it's not like the computer is giving
wider a big big advantage but it just
suggested as one of the best defensive
tries and very tough to to play move
okay rook a one Bishop b5 okay okay now
see three years threatened and yeah
cards and played played h3 again the
computer wants to play root be one
trying to defend note that not deform
can not already be answered with this
yeah this is now really really quick on
the queenside and black will win there
is this move and rook be 3c three just
too much on the queenside it now really
is is very very tough to defend this is
plagued by nakamura he wants to prevent
any Knight g4 business and give the King
some room but it seems to be too slow
this rook be one move again mr.
suggested i DM rook d to c 8 yeah of the
same supporting the pawns and now King
age tube was played yeah and I think
after that why does so what is lost
really again the computer wants to play
this move which is also good for black
already but probably it at least keeps
the game going after King age 21 c 3 we
can now look at a completely false
sequence III
night moves at the Sun it is attacked 94
took on b2 group to be one and Roxy for
this is totally forced and the next
moves also the night has just attacked
it must take on b5 the only move rook
takes it to ya now we are moved from 41
so the time travel was was over and here
nakamura played 94 and yeah he could
have played night XD 6 that's also most
however after Luke d8 it does not really
help much this is attacked and why does
not have a good square if he goes to be
five for example there is this check and
92 which promotes the beep on the attack
abouna went to deform and here
councilman quite uncharacteristically
missed a very direct window well he had
seen the game continuation which also
probably wins but it's not so decisive
see a b3 was the the hardest the other
the toughest continuation for white
after that you're really lost um the
problem is ok white obviously cannot
take this is very easy and what Black is
just threatening here is something like
rook before attacking the knight and if
it moves there is this this sequence um
or alternatively something like that
will just promote the pond so this would
have been even quicker he played rock t
2 after 96 rupee 8 um yeah and here it's
quite quite remarkable that Nakamura
didn't play Knight takes 5 because this
really would have put up some resistance
I mean it's probably losing but
what you should should try at least Im
night xe5 rook takes d5 rue k 2ya going
to this rook ending after Luke takes e4
rope takes takes rook takes there is
king g7 and the King invades this is
very very likely lost but ok it seems a
bit tougher than the game he played rook
a 4 and this end game is also the reason
why this b3 move was a bit bit more
precise because after that white just
resigns in a couple of moves and this
end game we could have dragged on yeah
here after night d3 the pawn is just
just too strong we had had this this
happening and now black will yeah
basically when the exchange one of those
rooks needs to go for the father porn
and now the the two rooks being very
active am i doing a nicer mop-up job
here the night on before is also without
any any good outpost check check yeah
this was the conclusion of the game
rupees 98 and after rookie aid Nakamura
resigned yeah night f7 could have been
the follow-up and now Luke t5 traps in
the night and black we'll just just win
this piece following something like King
here Andrew gave eight for example it is
just trapped so tragic outcome again for
Nakamura was simply yeah cannot convert
a good position against Carlton I mean
I'm not quite sure how to how to
describe it I mean he lost ready he lost
10 games and classical town control now
didn't win any and out of if you look at
those losses I mean from the 10 losses
they are maybe five or six straight
forward once but there are really some
games where he had very
good position and this is one of one of
those games I mean in the Iran move
26-year this this this spot where he
could have played night takes h5 this
would have been very very strong
probably winning I mean somewhere around
here there are more than one interesting
ways to play and here he actually didn't
do a bad job but he never really am
increased the advantage to to such
extent that that causal was totally
totally lost he missed this chance here
and after that it always was a bit murky
and not not at all easy to play and ya
can't always went for the for the most
active defense didn't ya didn't play any
any passive moves always try to keep his
chances intact even if it was
objectively not great they always were
some chances for black so for this
tournament it means that cousin is
taking the lead again now with he has
this really strange pattern he won two
games from the start in round one and
two then a draw then two losses now two
wins again and both wins with black so
I'm quite quite remarkable um it's also
quite quite scary to to notice that now
he has got a plus to score and this is
not even good enough to keep his writing
so so high is the rating at the moment
that he has okay so um tomorrow we have
from Council playing wide against kawana
very interesting matchup of course as
Kara wanna I had one this very
convincing game in the first turn of the
tournament so would be very interesting
to see what Carson is is doing with with
white against Cara wanna and yeah very
interesting game yet again well it's
almost guaranteed between the two
players to to get a good and interesting
game
and for those who want to know my game
that I played today I applied to draw
today in a league game which was very
important we had the final the final
round of our our leak the third Liga
Germany and with this we played them
drawing the overall match we tied on
match for form which meant that we are
what we is that we stay in our league
and don't get relegated to to the link
below was very important match and very
glad that we managed that my game wasn't
terribly exciting for those of who might
want to want to see it it was a drawing
about 20 moves I had equalised quite
easily with black and the draw was very
ok for the overall standings of the of
the match ok so thanks for watching this
and I'll be back tomorrow with a new
round round eight thanks for watching